alors maintenant on va passer à vos
ouvrages peu discouru là comme ça mais
maintenant je vais commencer par le
vôtre william boyd vous avez quel âge 32
ans et vous avez écrit combien de roman
un trois romans et une collection des
nouvelles c'est ça donc et en celui ci
comme neige au soleil est la deuxième
des siennes c'est le deuxième ris c'est
ça pour moi j'écoute et je vais vous
dire tout de suite j'ai été enthousiasmé
par votre roman
quand j'ai commencé non seulement
j'avais pas de finir parce que c'est
toujours mieux quand on a fini un roman
qu'on aime bien mais surtout je ne
pouvais pas supporter que téléphone que
me dérange les enfants absolument
j'étais insupportable la journée où j'ai
lu votre livre et je vais même aller
plus loin je pense que les gens qui
achèteront environ votre livre votre
roman
et bien moi je prends l'engagement que
si l'une de ces personnes si là les
téléspectateurs et déçu je suis prêt lui
rembourser votre livre non je suis très
exigeant et si j'en prends l'engagement
public blanche vous avez vu que je
prends beaucoup de risques eh bien je
prends aucun risque je ne prends
strictement aucun risque parce que je
suis persuadé qu'un lecteur normalement
constitué ne peut pas ne pas lire avec
passion ce le roman vous avez écrit
d'accord bon alors d'abord le sujet
d'abord c'est un sujet qu'on connaît pas
à nous les français fait je gueule parce
qu'on ne sommes pas de cette génération
mais pas les anglais n'ont les objets
non plus donc il y avait pendant la
guerre de 14 18 il ya eu une guerre en
afrique orientale qui a opposé les
anglais aux allemands oui parce qu'ils
avaient des possessions qui était il ya
les deux de colonies à côté l'une à
l'autre
et quand la guerre en europe à commencer
ils ont commencé à se battre en afrique
aussi et c'est bizarre c'est tout à fait
bizarre c'est tout à fait à mesure mais
la guerre en afrique a continué
trois semaines plus lent que la guerre
en europe parce que les général ne
peuvent pas trouver les armes et
lorsqu'ils sont au milieu d'afrique
en plein de se battre et pas de
téléphone pas des agneaux chose comme
soirée trois semaines après l'armistice
en europe
il y avait là l'armistice en afrique est
alors au début on a l'impression vous
allez nous raconter une guerre de
perrette parce que bien des noirs il ya
des blancs ya des indiens il ya des sud
africains et des anglais des allemands
dont celui tout ça va être assez rigolo
et puis et puis c'est pas vrai du tout
c'est une guerre abominable
d'ailleurs toutes les guerres mais c'est
vrai qu'une guerre abominable oui
absolument c'est pas comme quand l'idée
générale de la première guerre mondiale
parce que c'est 7 est une guerre de
mouvement une guerre de guérilla aussi
et avec une gêne à l'allemand très très
intelligente et une générale formidable
qui qui s'est échappé toutes les fois
des anglais des britanniques et les
lézards mi temps pire et c'était assez a
comme accablants comme tout les guerres
mondiales et 10 au début les anglais ont
été battus souvent vous le racontez puis
après bon les anglais ont pris le mesure
de where les allemands eon alors il ya
des personnages vous racontez pas ce
mondial il ya six personnages principaux
ouais il ya un couple d'allemands
il ya un américain qui se trouve dans
cette guerre qui luttons garage
il y avait beaucoup d américains en
amérique à cette époque c'est bizarre
aussi mais c'est vrai vous dites que cet
américain est resté là bas parce qu'il
avait accompagné le président roosevelt
dans un safari
oui c'est ça ça c'est une faute anti
roosevelt a tué un tas d anne moulin en
afrique
c'est épars à cette époque en 1900 et 9
c'est bon alors il ya donc ce couple
d'allemands cet américain et puis il ya
trois onglets deux frères et puis une
femme qui elle ne va pas en afrique du
sud qui reste en angleterre qui est
l'épousé de l'un des deux frères qui va
devenir la maîtresse de l'autre mais
cette femme
en vérité c'est une vraie victimes de
cette guerre pourrait combler comme les
deux frères aussi comme la comme les
allemands aussi
oui mais ils sont là bas ils se battent
pour israël elle reste en angleterre et
elle est quand même la victime
oui je pense que
ça c'était normal pour les femmes des
soldats pendant la première guerre
mondiale parce que tout le monde ont été
tués ou blessés comme ça c'est ils sont
aussi les victimes alors ce qui est tout
à fait extraordinaire dans votre cas
c'est que vous vous raconter donc une
guerre mais vous mêlez très habilement
la bouffonnerie au tragique vous mêlez
sais pas comment dire le presque
l'innocence à la innocence au cynisme je
sais pas quel mot doit pas employer des
mots trop forts mais c'est un peu ça le
l'ironie il ya un peu tout ça parce
qu'on ne sait jamais au fond si vous
êtes tout à fait sérieux ou si vous vous
moquez pas ou au contraire si vous ne
vous n'allez pas nous raconter cette je
suis très sérieux mais je pense que la
guerre est comme ça et la vie est comme
ça aussi mais dans une guerre vous
pouvez voir plus clairement
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans la vie c'est ça
c'est une symbol delà de la condition
humaine si vous voulez mais je suis très
sérieux la gare je pense est chaotique
c'est absurde s'est déterminé par lazard
et il n'y a aucune raison donc une
stratégie stratégie qui qui peut marcher
dans une guerre c'est une erreur de
penser ça mais qu'est le film
extraordinaire évidemment un film qui
serait très coûteux si vous devez
tourner votre histoire mais des
milliards mais seulement 12 $
disponibles mais bon il y avait quand
même des scènes drôles il ya par exemple
quand des millions de des millions de da
bay met en fuite
les troupes anglaises ça c'est
authentique quand c'est arrivé pendant
la bataille du temps là et puis c'est
vrai alors là où on voit quand même ces
scènes étonnantes
il ya cet américain the brave américain
qui a une femme qui est juste à la
frontière de de la dépossession
allemande
et puis les son voisin allemand prendre
pour prendre sa ferme une brûle toutes
les récoltes et l'américain va voir sa
compagnie d'assurances ont écouté j'ai
eu des dégâts soyez gentils comme
remboursé et il vient avec le courtier
devant la maison parce que le courtier
dit fait son boulot il dit je vais
contrôler les dégâts évidemment le
courtier se fait tuer en faisant son
travail
ça c'est une invention vote par oui
absolument rigeur noir ça ça doit rester
ambigu je prends dans un sens oui mais
autre chose vous montrer c'est que les
héros il ya des personnages sont des
héros dans ce livre mais ils ne
deviennent pas héros parce que défendre
leur patrie ils deviennent pour des
raisons presque égoïste oui mais je
pense que dans les romans de guerre il y
a trop dayraut et les gars c'est sûr que
qui les zéros existe mais je pense que
c'est pas tout à fait vrai de écrire au
sujet des héros pendant la guerre pour
le poulet sur les soldats pour les les
femmes des soldats c'est une affaire
triste c'est une sphère très très
difficile à supporter et alors je veux
pas dire pas des vrais airs héros dans
un roman quel est votre avis daniel
rondeau qui est libérable j'ai trouvé
que c'était un livre tout à fait
extraordinaire d'une part le saint livre
de guerre ou
la guerre se moque des militaires
d'autre part ça un livre aussi dame
d'amour ou le sexe se moque des
sentiments et le tout et est bâti est
monté avec une précision incroyable ah
oui pour incroyable et si on regarde la
fin on va pas du tout dévoiler ce qui
serait commandes commence et termine le
vivre est ce qu'on peut dire tout de
suite c'est que l'électeur qui vont
arriver le plus vite possible à la fin
ils vont avoir l'impression un moment
que le livre se finit il est quasiment
une passe d'une page blanche est en fête
william boyd a monté trois phases
successives et tout aussi crédible et
c'est là qu'on voit aussi de jeu par le
côté artisans de luxe quad il va un
trait qui 32 ans à l'argent proche et
qu'une chose à ce livre c'est son titre
son titre parce que j'aime pas du tout
ce titre comme neige au soleil
qu'est ce que c'est la neige au soleil
c'est de l'eau alors si un livre qui ne
ressemble pas de l'osé bien celui ci au
moins à l'eau de rose mais l'aîné titres
en anglais c'est impossible de traduire
chez tran huy nommé koné le soleil ça va
pas je sais que c'est justifié par
l'ailier allemand et oui il ya un lettre
qui est au début du roman qui explique
le titre mais en anglais c'est un titre
très difficile à traduire et je pense
que ça c'est aussi proches que possible
pour moi d'accord quand je vais lui
trouver un autre type
le bold je trouve que l'afrique c'est le
décor de cette histoire et qu'elle est
présent par des paysages mais qu'elle
est complètement absente
disons les personnages sont renfermés
dans leur propre relation est ce que
c'est par respect pour disons le pays où
l'action se passe que vous n'avez pas
davantage impliquer les personnages par
exemple n'y a pas de personnages
africains à part les silhouettes de oui
à part les silhouettes de son dû et
surtout il ya des silhouettes de soldats
ou de domestique ce cd libre et parce
que les gens oui les gens à cette époque
on penser comme ça je m'en étais et j'ai
raconte l'histoire au point de vue de
mes six personnages et j'ai essayé de de
les faire comme les personnages
authentiques de l'époque édouardien en
angleterre ou en allemand ou en afrique
j'ai une amie qui lorsqu'il leur égard
la peinture abstraite il se pose
toujours une question si l'auteur serait
destinée au cheval alors vous savez bien
dessiné les chevals j'en suis sûr
non seulement un cheval mais quand vous
présentez un nouveau personnage vous les
faites jade hui l votre savoir faire
vous le faites attendre quelques temps
et il est il derrière tout de suite
visible comme par exemple mr which
browning avec samuel récalcitrants
vous savez je crois que le roman de
william blake
c'est une preuve
parce que on dit souvent on dit souvent
qu'on ne peut pas écrire un bon moment
aujourd'hui parce que c'est un genre de
passer au qui souvent dit souvent on dit
souvent mais non pas du tout oui c'est
un meilleur tri moi j'aime la narration
long dans un roman et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui et la nation les normands
d'aujourd'hui manquent la narration peu
d'invention d'invention l'action des
choses que je veux que les choses à
préparer et à l'action il y en a neuf et
si nous arrivons bien vous changez votre
micro parce qu'il paraît qu'on vous
entendez allons en profiter vous reviens
moi j'ai été ébloui par ce lire ce qui
m'a le plus ému ce sont ses deux frères
or on sait dès le début et c'est
merveilleusement dit qu'il y à un plot
d'amour qui va du jeune qui le jeune qui
s'appelle selick qui seront mariage de
son frère
et malheureusement on il devait dire le
discours et on donne ça un imbécile qui
récite je ne sais quelle bêtise et il
est blessé et il a revu son frère qui
n'a pas vu depuis si longtemps et on
voit l'amour entre ces deux entre
phoenix et gabriel qui est un personnage
très beau le blond avec la grande figure
carré et félix lebrun qui a tout les dn
il un bouton sur un site du risque il
est il a une jeunesse impatiente il et
il se débrouille mal en amour ça va pas
hélas au frais et puis toute l'histoire
avec toute l'épopée à travers l'afrique
on va penser qu'à une chose c'est que le
jeune va aller retrouver le grand
gabriel et puis va leur arriver tant de
choses affreux dans cette femme avait
vraiment pas
nous raconte rien je vis dans cette
femme et j'ai pas dit son nom bien